what what if the UFC thing was like bold
and interesting when you were a young
guy do you think you would have I would
have a hundred percent done it and I
probably would have a much harder time
having this conversation that's right
yeah for sure yeah so I think I think I
think you hit the sweet spot where you
got the skills you've been in a training
idiom you really know what you're
talking about and you're getting
front-row seats but not actually having
to have your brain particularly take the
pounding there's no getting away from
that if that is the unfortunate reality
that every fighter accepts there's no
getting away from that there's there's
an absolute possibility and it's not
just your head it's also your joints the
big part is your back and your neck I
know many guys that have neck
impingements and disc herniations and
fused neck discs and then nerve pinch
where their nerves are impinged to the
point where they have atrophy and their
arms I know several guys who have that
where they have one arm that's smaller
than the other arm and it severely
impedes their ability to move and they
used to be world champions two guys that
have been on the show bas Rutten Pat
Miletich two of the greatest of all time
both guys have one small arm in one
regular-sized arm because of neck
impingement so their nerves are
literally pinched down by all the
swelling and scar tissue and damaged
discs yeah well since we became friends
I started just casually looking at this
world and it's utterly fascinating I
mean there's there's nothing like it
well the jiu-jitsu world I think you
would there's there's two different
worlds right there's the MMA world which
incorporates all the different martial
arts and then there's the jujitsu world
and the jujitsu world I think you would
like out yes yeah I'd love it because
it's basically but to call it chess is
not quite fair right because it's more
complex than chess there's much more
degrees of freedom or so high but it's
also easier to win if someone's better
than chess cuz like you even if someone
is fairly competent and chess will take
a few moves to beat them and jujitsu if
someone's fairly competent the other one
is a master it'd probably crush you very
quickly but the when you watch two
really high-level guys trying to set
each other up it's this crazy
rolling exercise and leverage and
position and unless the knowledge of
moves that Eddie Bravo versus crazy yeah
it's hard to even know what's going on
it's crazy if you don't know it's one of
my more difficult challenges of being in
a commentator is when the fight goes to
the ground explaining to people watching
at home what he wants to do right now is
get his right leg over his arm and as
soon as he does that now that arm is
stuck he's in trouble right now yeah you
know I'd like to try to explain that to
people so they could follow along go oh
I see I see
and he's gonna grab that he's gonna arch
his back and he tapped and people go oh
oh and he gets people really excited
about jujitsu because they see that and
go oh this is like really complicated
like he's got there's like a dance he's
doing the other guy's trying to resist
it the first time I saw the Gracie
breakdown of particular fights where
they've committed to memory every move
yeah and it's like replaying the great
games of like morphine chess and you're
just thinking wow that okay there's the
Evergreen game there's the immortal game
and that that to me is fascinating but
it's actually more interesting to me in
the UFC arena because of the fact that
that's only a component and that it's
yes it's what I didn't understand was
how much we could get close to
unrestricted fighting and still have
people fairly dependably survived with
minimal obvious disfigure disfigurement
there is even there are some we could
even be safer if we eliminated weight
cutting the weight cutting is the number
one health issue in the sport in my
opinion here number two is the brain
damage and the impact and you know
broken bones and things along those
lines but the number one is weight
cutting because it's so unnecessary it's
such a such an issue that needs to be
addressed because these guys want to
compete at the highest weight possible
say do you know how it works no okay so
if you were gonna compete in the 170
pound division but you actually weighed
190 what you would do is you would wait
until you would follow a pretty strict
diet keep your bodyweight in your fat a
certain level and then when it comes
down to a few days before you would
dehydrate yourself pretty radically yeah
and then rehydrate yourself
scientifically using the crow there's a
bunch of guys like george lockhart guys
who are x
in this and then they give you the exact
right amount of nutrients right around
the potassium and zinc and they want to
replenish all of your electrolytes and
get you in a perfect balance but you're
still compromised and if you don't have
a guy like a George Lockhart or someone
who's a real expert in nutrition and
understands biology and can get you back
into that position
you're most likely going to compete
compromised but you can accept that
significant compromising because you're
going to be a bigger person than the
person you're fighting but they also
like in boxing in particular the vast
majority of deaths have occurred in the
lighter weight divisions and a lot of it
is not just because of the head trauma
but because it's head trauma and someone
who's dehydrated that's interesting yeah
it's like it's it's it sucks and it's
it's contrary to what martial arts are
supposed to be about martial arts
supposed to be about skill for skill
it's not supposed to be about cheating
and the cheating thing is like you're
dehydrating yourself it's extension
cheating you're saying you're 170 pounds
you put your your like if you say this
the 170 pound champion and get on scale
he's 193 what the [ __ ] going on this
isn't a hunting seventy pound how
frustrating if I want to meet you in a
different class like I wanted to fight
you my whole life but we're really
separated well you can lose weight the
right way look if somebody wants to
compete at 170 pounds in my humble
opinion they should actually weigh 170
pounds my friend cam Haines is a ultra
marathon runner and one of the things
that he does when he gets ready for
ultra marathons is he lose his body
weight but he doesn't have any body
weight to lose so he'll he'll burn 3,000
calories and eat 2,000 calories and
that's how he lose his way he lets his
body eat itself so he gets down to the
160s and that's when he runs these
gigantic long races like 240 miles but I
know he's done this you can do this like
you don't have to dehydrate yourself but
they choose to dehydrate themselves
because they replenish and then they get
much bigger when they get inside the
Octagon when he's 165 he's actually 165
that's just what he weighs and that's a
the best way to run 240 miles so he does
it through discipline but these guys
that are doing it and it's not their
fault because it's already been
established it's a part of the sport
it's been there for years and years and
years and it's it's sanctioned cheating
and everybody does it and it's the worst
part of the sport because it's really
damaging to your kidneys yeah terrible
for your organs your body starts to shut
down when you do it too often your body
doesn't want to lose weight anymore so
it starts to really hold on to that
water and guys fall out let's sleep and
pass out and bang their heads off walls
and fights get cancelled like probe like
championship level fights get cancelled
because guys blackout and crack their
head off the wall and this is this has
happened in the in the UFC before it's
just super super unnecessary and
unfortunate and part of it is because
there's not enough weight classes
there's like you know there's 155 then
there's 170 the difference between 155
and 170 is not just 15 pounds because if
you actually weigh 155 and this guy's
dropping down to 170 that [ __ ]
could be 190 plus right and he's just
figuring out a way to cut weight to get
down to there and that happens all the
time so you're dealing with you know it
could be 25 30 pounds difference between
you two guys if you're if you actually
weigh with the weight class is when you
get into the Octagon so people are
forced to drop weight they're forced to
go lower if they want to compete at a
world-class level they're forced to take
this extra risk and it could be
mitigated it could it could all be
stopped by hydration test the the UFC
could step in all the athletic
commissions could step in and say enough
is enough you're gonna fight it wet your
way and we're gonna give you more weight
classes so you can figure out what's the
weight for you to be best at and I hope
it doesn't take someone dying before
they figure this out